le texte qui sera peut-être voté à
Poznan stipule que tous les pays dont la
France bien évidemment devront produire
20 % d'énergie renouvlable d'ici à 2020
en France la façade maritime est
tellement importante qu'on commence à
vraiment s'intéresser aux énergies
marines il y a déjà l'usine marée
motrice de la Rance qui existe depuis
les années 60 mais aussi des projets
d'hydrolienne à Pinol ou encore
d'utilisation de la force de la houle
c'est au Croisic quand la mer nous
éclaire le reportage est signé p bonnet
et Daniel
Levy prenez toutes les centrales
électriques du monde elles produisent
près de 2000 milliards de Wat et bien
cette énergie colossale c'est très
exactement celle qu'on pourrait puiser
des océans grâce à leur inépuisable
mouvement puiser l'énergie de la mer la
France a été la première à y penser il y
a 40 ans dans l'estuire de la Rance 24
turbines sont installées pour exploiter
la marée l'usine marée motrice fournie
aujourd'hui en électrique ité de quoi
alimenter une ville de 300000 habitants
un vrai succès mais depuis aucun autre
projet d'envergure n'a vu le jour tu
veux je lance quoi commeou pourtant des
idées il y en
a cette coque flottante testée dans le
bassin de l'École centrale de Nant
amplifie le mouvement des vagues autre
technologie l'hydrolienne l'éolienne qui
tourne sous l'eau ce prototype est en ce
moment immergé au large de benodé dans
le finisterè le potentiel de ces
machines n'est pas négligeable en 2020
on pourrait aisément aisément avoir 1 %
de la consommation électrique française
couverte avec ces énergies marines mais
d'autres pays ont eu des options
beaucoup plus ambitieuses encore
puisqu'ils pensent en Écosse pouvoir
produire jusqu'à 20 % de
l'électricité cette grosse bouée
développée par les écossais qui pompent
l'énergie de la houle a d'ailleurs déjà
pris du service au Portugal elle
alimente 1500 foyers sans rejet de CO2
en France EDF a choisi d'installer les
hydroliennes plus discrètes dans le
paysage ici au large de pimpul à partir
de